lucky number seven is one that i know
i'm gonna get heat for please don't
attack me i'm sorry
i'm sorry i'm sorry i've watched a lot
of medical dramas over the last two
years
some of them really good and some of
them that need a little bit of
improvement
a little bit and to cap off the year i'm
gonna be ranking them from least
to most accurate if you disagree with me
on any of these on the list
drop it down below in the comments i
want to know your thoughts let's get
started
number 16 the least accurate medical
drama that i watched on this channel
is attaway general sorry to my dixie
dimlio fans out there but the
show just has inaccuracies galore the
uniforms aren't right they're wearing
hair nets at times they're having
teenagers deliver medical care as
volunteers i literally remember one
scene when they were trying to save
someone's life where the doctor was like
checking a pulse like this and the ekg
monitor just has colorful strips going
across it that mean absolutely nothing
just nothing makes sense
on the show i get that it's young folks
they're trying their first time at
acting and i support that
more power to them i'm strictly talking
about the medical accuracy
number 15 and the second least accurate
medical drama
doogie howser i can't believe it's this
low on the list but the reality is it's
an older show
so the medical accuracy is just not up
to par to
our current standards also i really
remember this one very awkward scene
whoa maybe that kind of stuff was okay
back then
now it definitely freaked me out number
14 nurses
i watched you with my good friend nurse
bianca who also was heavy critical of
the show there's just a lot of
inaccuracies they don't follow a lot of
the medical guidelines
literally on the episode they had one of
the nurses
attacking another nurse for treating
someone who was a known criminal
we treat everybody in the medical space
so that made no sense and then in
another scene they had a doctor just say
oh we ran out of oh blood so i'm just
going to connect myself because i'm old
blood
and give it to the patient like no sir
we don't do that that is highly
inaccurate i'm calling bs
i love nurses they're the backbone of
medicine the show itself didn't do them
justice
lucky 13 is transplant i really like the
premise of this one we have a syrian
refugee that's thrust back into
practicing medicine in canada i was
really excited for it to work however in
the very first scene you have an
individual who's not a doctor in canada
drilling into someone's head in order to
save their life throughout the entire
episode no one was doing chest
compressions they were talking about
intubating people getting cardiac
consults where were the chest
compressions
chest compressions chest compressions
chest compressions folks
for number 12 we have royal pains
the medical accuracy is just out of this
world it's almost like they're
functioning like an er
specialist family medicine doctor
interventional cardiologist toxicologist
it's like they're super human he didn't
even look at her eyes how does he know
what her pupils look like it sounds like
he has x-ray vision he could see from
across the room
that is not how a medical diagnosis is
made and i feel like it misguides people
into thinking doctors have to know right
away what's going on a lot of times we
don't and we have to investigate further
by the way all the medical dramas i'm
ranking now and i've reviewed in the
past
are linked down below so if you want to
watch one of those in more detail
check it out number 11 we have the night
shift
i know that there's a lot of fans on
this show and they may be upset seeing
their
favorite medical drama this slow on the
list it's just
not so medically accurate at least to be
fair the one episode i watched
they had one doctor completely lose his
mind
like there was just so much unrealistic
actions happening by the staff that it
made it feel not medically accurate
again
the procedures they showed the medical
illnesses they showed were so far out
there that you probably wouldn't even
find them in a medical book it would
have to be a sub-sub-specialist
medical book in order to find these
conditions number 10 falling somewhere
in the middle of the list
is nurse jackie now this show is darker
than most medical dramas on this list
and i actually really
enjoyed the depth of the show however
the characters were just
so aggressive in their illegal action if
she forged his
organ donor certificate on the back of
his license that's crazy like there's
just so many things that keep happening
to make it seem outrageous to make it
interesting
it doesn't feel quite realistic coming
in at number nine
the resident i actually got invited by
one of the cast members to be on the set
with them got a behind-the-scenes tour
super cool
all that's linked down below i think the
show falls somewhere in the middle of
the pack when it comes to medical
accuracy they use a lot of good medical
terms that are accurate their procedures
are performed with a decent level of
accuracy the one thing that i will say
is the
residents on the show are really like
cowboy residents they're doing whatever
they want
you do whatever the hell i tell you no
questions asked so that really isn't
realistic
and just like any good medical drama the
drama's turned up
all time high while i dig the drama the
realism falls somewhere right down the
middle
definitely one i enjoy though and i
recommend you check out as well number
eight we have new amsterdam
all in all i think it's a good show it's
quality it talks about
really important systemic issues within
healthcare well i think it takes on
important challenges
it also does it in a very unrealistic
way at times well everyone in the
cardiac surgical department please
raise your hands great thank you
you're all fired like that is not
realistic who's gonna take care of the
patients in the meantime
i definitely want to check more episodes
out of that show if you have a specific
episode of new amsterdam you want me to
watch drop it down below lucky number
seven
is one that i know i'm gonna get heat
for please don't attack me i'm sorry
i'm sorry i'm sorry i'm sorry i'm saying
it now i'm sorry
grey's anatomy i know i know it's so
it's it's not it's not that accurate i
know it's the most
popular medical drama of all time
probably and look i've watched four
episodes of it on this channel i
probably watched maybe a handful more on
my own and it's just
not medically accurate residents and
interns are doing
all sorts of advanced procedures with no
oversight romance around every corner
and heartbreak and drama and i know why
so many of you love it i get it i like
it too it's
but still medical accuracy just it's not
there for number six we have scrubs
yes the famous famous satirical medical
show scrubs
i honestly struggled with this one i
didn't know where to place it i know
many of you
at home on forums say scrubs is the most
accurate show
however i do think that it is an
accurate satirical
explanation of what happens or
representation of what happens in
hospitals but it is not
medically accurate get her to open her
mouth take a handful and
throw it at her whatever sticks that's
the correct dosage
and it's a comedy so i get why they're
doing it and i enjoy watching it but
one of the things that kind of irks me
with the show maybe because i'm so
defensive and protective of my patients
is i feel like they're mean to their
patients sometimes and i know it's a
joke but somehow it just gets in here
for me
number five we have chicago med a lot of
these shows really just focus on doctors
and chicago med really does a great job
at showing nurses
as part of the medical team the episode
that i watched i couldn't find almost
anything medically wrong with it it has
good medical terminology
the procedures that they're doing are
accurate and the fact that they had a
nurse
telling a resident how to do chest
compressions properly they were
critiquing them
that got me hyped number four we have
code black this is the surprising one on
the list
the dark horse the black sheep if you
will i
really fell in love with this show it
actually genuinely upset me to find out
it was canceled the show felt like it
was written by medical professionals and
then someone added a little drama
as opposed to someone that writes
medical dramas and then they sprinkled
some medicine into it i think the the
real
hard-hitting truth about the show is it
does a good job
at showing character development of
medical professionals
the stresses we have the struggles we
have how we go about losing patients and
talking with patients i think
those were very real and clearly
scripted by someone who's gone through
that process let's bring it back let's
resurrect code black who's with me
number three we have house md i know so
many house fans wanted him to be number
one
and while the show has incredible
scientific rigor
like it talks about true scientific
conditions a lot of the zebra conditions
that we've talked about on this channel
ones that warrant more attention and
while i think that's great
i think the way that my manhouse md goes
about it is just
reckless i want to check for erdheim
chester how does he know what that is
i've never even heard of it he's
funny he's interesting he's he's wacky
he argues with people but also the
residents and the fellows that are with
him
they each bring their own unique spin on
the show so i'm a huge fan i want to
watch more episodes of house md and i
have it third on my list
i wonder where it falls on yours we're
at the top
two folks it's getting serious the
competition is heating up
number two is the good doctor
dr sean comes in with the accuracy
depicting a true medical professional
who is diagnosed with autism but is
still doing their job phenomenally when
they talk about medical conditions
the way that they talk about it in a
reasonable easy to understand way but
still using medical terminology
is awesome i love that they manage to
inject humor even some of the most
dark spots
do you need me to listen to you anymore
no that's how real life works that's how
medicine works i actually just watched
the good doctor covent 19 episode that's
linked down below
well worth a watch number one king of
medical dramas
at least in medical accuracy at least in
my book it is two letters
e r that's right folks it's an oldie but
it's a classic it's so good
20 30 years later since its inception
it's still bingeable it's still quality
it still
tells real-life stories about humans the
issues that we run into hospitals to
this very day
still apply to the episodes that are
found in er it's truly one of my
favorite medical dramas
the medical accuracy is really solid
don't get me wrong
they sometimes go overboard and they
make diagnoses too quickly or too
dramatically but the accuracy the heart
of the show
especially with how long the show has
been around how many careers it's made
george clooney it's number one in my
books i know you want to disagree with
me i know you have other thoughts and i
want to hear your thoughts hit me in the
comments down below tell me what your
list looks like tell me
which one of these you disagree with
because i genuinely want to know if you
love one of these medical dramas and you
want me to watch a specific episode
don't hesitate to drop that in the
comments too i really enjoy all these
medical dramas
so i'm linking them all down below for
you or you could just click on this
playlist here
for my entire dr react series there's
medical dramas in here
untold stories of the er and so many
more click here and as always stay happy
and healthy